See a lot of videos on rife-like machines lately. They make some crazy claims. What do you think?
Excuse me. So there's a lot of videos
if you're watching YouTube, if you're watching Instagram, if you're watching TikTok, if you're watching Facebook,
you're watching any of the social media sites. There's a lot of alternative help
influencers that have flooded the market.
Talking about rife machines, talking about different supplements, talking about different cures for
this disease, that disease, including cancer. I can't tell you how many calls that we had
getting where people are asking questions thinking, oh, I can't wait till the med bed comes out,
because that can grow limbs. There's so many false and outrageous claims about things. It is just,
I tell you, from our perspective, as a clinic that we're trying to do things honestly,
and not make claims that are unethical, immoral. I don't know how people can do these things
and still have a conscience. But then you reminded that the Bible is very clear that in the last days,
people's consciousness will be seared and they will just lie through their teeth to do anything.
Jesus called the Pharisees the synagogue of Satan that they only do is speak lies because
lied is their native language. So it is just, it is so hard. Never before in my practice, of course,
I'm an old guy and I've been doing this for 40 years. But never before have I seen so many people come
thinking that if they just do XYZ, they're going to be cured of their disease, whether it be cancer
or some autoimmune disease because they saw a TikTok video or because they saw a Instagram video.
It's just so sad how many people are bad-boozled by just easy lies. So I would caution everybody to
be careful of what you see out there. I too have seen a bunch of videos on rife machines. And you
click on the website because I'm kind of a junkie for what is another therapy going to do to help
my patients get better. So I look into it and boy, they have some very classy ads. They've spent
a fortune on their fancy-dancy website and paid companies to make wonderful AI videos that
that make their machine look like it could grow limbs. Matter of fact, that is one of the comments that
is on the med bed that was so big in, you know, it's all first of, you know, when it came out several
years ago, literally people were making claims that it could literally grow limbs back. And this is a
rife machine. It's just, I just, and the FDA came after them. I just, this is so bad because these
kind of false claims and things and these videos that show just miraculous healing. I'm not saying
that people aren't miraculously healed. I'm saying that the only way you are healed is miraculous
healing. But to say that some tool is going to miraculously heal everybody that uses it, whether you
have ulcerative colitis or you have prostate cancer, is just alive from the pit of hell. And these
things hurt ultimately hurt alternative practitioners because then the FDA has grounds to literally
shut everybody down because these claims are out there that are such false claims. So I'd caution you
against those things. These companies are fly by net companies. The FDA is going to shut them down.
They're going to be gone. And they can say whatever they want because they're not practitioners. So
they don't have, you know, boards looking after what they say and what they claim. So I would caution
you against, and I've said this multiple times, caution you and against these
natural alternative practitioners that have gotten into the space simply because they want to get,
you know, 500,000 followers so that they can end up making money off their videos and that they
make claims and say things on the videos that are full of half truths. And they just get shares and
likes and and comments and and they make money doing that. And that's that is what they do. And it's just
it's frustrating from my point of view, quite honestly, it makes me want to not do this anymore. So
I don't be fooled by the lies that are out there. That's what I can best make a comment about
what I should like there.